the tensions between russia and ukraine
have sparked a huge crisis in europe the
likes of which has not been seen since
the cold war so who are the key players
and what is their role in all of this
[Music]
first of all right at the center of it
all is vladimir putin the president of
russia he has been the most powerful
figure in the country for over two
decades
an intelligence officer for 16 years
before he has done more to shape modern
russia than anyone else in the last 20
years he believes that ukrainians and
russians are one people
the soviet union arose thanks to the
bolshevik policy
now its descendants have demolished
lenin's monuments in ukraine
they call it decommunization
you want to be decommunized well we're
quite fine with that but don't stop
halfway we are ready to show you what
decommunizing ukraine really means
sergey lavrov has been the foreign
minister since 2004 and is almost
universally respected by both friends
and foes as a wily tough operator a
chain smoking whiskey lover he's been
the face of russia's diplomatic efforts
in the current ukraine spat and in a
clearly staged video released by the
kremlin has encouraged putin to keep
giving talks with the west a chance
[Music]
to
then there's the siloviki the security
men around putin who are said to have a
lot of influence over his thinking
nikolai patrichev is the head of
russia's powerful security council a
public inquiry in the uk found that he
was probably responsible for ordering
the killing of alexander litvinenko in
london
he echoes putin's views on ukraine as a
protectorate of the country and has
called it a total absurdity that russia
is threatening ukraine
then there's sergey narishkin head of
russia's foreign intelligence agency the
former kgb officer compared ukraine's
government to hitler's occupation he's
played a prominent role in promoting
favorable interpretations of russian
history
essential to the ukrainian conflict are
the two separatist regions in donbass
the so-called donetsk and luhansk
people's republics
since 2014 these mostly russian-speaking
regions have been controlled by
pro-russian separatists and roughly
fifteen thousand people have been killed
in their conflict with the ukrainian
government the leader in donetsk dennis
puscilin has warned that a full-scale
war could break
[Music]
has had a unique rise to power he is a
former actor and comedian who actually
played the ukrainian president in the tv
show servant of the people he has made
it very clear that he wants ukraine to
join the eu and nato
ukraine
ukraine's desire to join the european
union to strengthen its borders you are
very well aware of it and we would like
nato membership which would be a
guarantee of our security
he has consistently played down the
conflict for fear of causing panic at
home and even more economic instability
but he has warned that conflict could
lead to a full-fledged war in europe
that approach by zilensky has at times
differed from the stance taken by
ukraine's foreign minister dimitro
kuliba
he's insisted that russia should make
clear the extent of its military buildup
on ukraine's borders
ukraine intends to push back against a
potential russian invasion if the
country's most senior soldier is
anything to go forward
for years now china and russia have been
growing closer with president xi jinping
recently hosting vladimir putin as guest
of honor at the beijing olympics in a
lengthy joint statement the two
countries criticized nato's expansion
rebuked certain states in the west for
the way they seek to impose their own
democratic standards on others and they
describe their friendship as having no
limits
[Music]
the key players in the crisis from
nato's perspective are the us uk france
and germany
since the conflict began the us
especially under joe biden has made the
unusual step of releasing regular
intelligence briefings about russia's
military movements
some have suggested this is a method of
deterrence and that the u.s has finally
learned how to carry out an information
war
emmanuel macron olaf schultz have also
played an important role and both have
visited putin and zelensky
but in the end what happens is really up
to just one person that's vladimir putin
and that's just the way he likes it
[Music]